Who am I rooting for in the NFL playoffs
this weekend literally anyone other than
the Patriots speaking of games let's
play one you tell me which of these
things isn't like the others okay okay
Joe Biden Elizabeth Warren that it will
work sherrod Brown you know the answer
of course you do you're smart as
evidenced by the fact that you're
watching this very video
it's sherrod Brown who doesn't fit
because well almost everyone knows Biden
Warren and Beto
and knows they are all very likely to be
running for president in 2020 and then
no one are not nearly as many people
know who shared Brown is or have any
clue that he's a potential 2020
candidate too but here's the thing
not only is Brown likely around for
president I think he's the Dark Horse
pick in the Democratic field sidebar did
you know the term Dark Horse comes from
a novel called the young Duke by famed
British politician Benjamin Disraeli it
does I looked it up on the Internet in
the book an unknown Dark Horse sweeps to
victory in a horse race mmm now why do I
think Brown can come out of nowhere and
challenge for a spot in the top tier of
candidates alongside the Biden's of the
world well I can make that case in three
simple ish points point number one
Brown is from Ohio the Midwest as you
may have heard unless you've taken up
residence on another planet over the
last few years is pretty pretty
important to winning the White House
Trump's victories in Ohio Wisconsin and
Michigan sealed his absolutely
improbable victory in 2016 so given that
there is some movement among Democrats
to nominate someone in 2020 who can
blunt Trump's appeal to Midwestern
voters who have traditionally voted
Democratic but who went for President
Trump in the last election antor Brown
he's been winning elections in Ohio
since the 1970s sur meuse Ohio Secretary
of State a member of Congress from the
Buckeye State and six 2006 a US senator
and Browns 2018 re-election race he won
by almost seven points even though Trump
had won the state by eight points just
two years before
point number two Brown is a longtime
liberal look it's gonna be hard for
anyone not named Joe Biden to win a
Democratic presidential primary in 2020
unless they are a loud and proud liberal
the vast vast majority of energy the
party is on the left and it's likely to
remain there for at least the duration
of Trump's time in office now in 2017
gov track rated Brown the 11th most
liberal senator and the chamber Browns
current score from the conservative
Heritage Foundation is a whopping three
percent his lifetime score from that
organization try 5% and it's that last
number that may matter the most
lots and lots of Democrats who are
running for president will cast
themselves as liberal champions some
like New York's Kirsten Gillibrand have
passed voting records that will make
that a bit of a tough sell others like
California's Kamala Harris are newer on
the national political scene and won't
have much of a voting record at all to
lean on to make the liberal case but
Brown has been fighting the fight for a
long time even when it wasn't so cool to
call yourself a liberal point number
three Brown is a populist amazingly
amazingly Donald Trump successfully cast
himself as the voice of the average Joe
in the 2016 election despite being a
billionaire who had literally never
lived outside of New York City
Trump was regarded by lots of voters
especially white male voters in the
Midwest as one of them to combat that
element of Trump's appeal Democratic
voters may well put significant value on
the ability of a candidate who can speak
the language of the working man and
avoid the appearance of coastal elitism
Brown fits the bill as that populist
antidote
Trump he spent the majority of his
political career arguing for the rights
of the little guy primarily as a front
and center advocate for labor unions
interesting sidenote Brown Wong were a
pin on his lapel of a canary in a
coalmine
canary in a coal mine to remind people
and himself about the struggles of
miners here's Brown quote populism and
patriotism are not racist they are not
anti-semitic they don't push some people
down in order to live some people up
they don't appeal to the darker side of
human nature and that's from an
interview with Vanity Fair in 2018 one
extra additional point in Browns favor
his voice okay since you've probably
never heard of brown before you know
right now you definitely don't know what
his voice sounds like so here it is we
will show America how we celebrate the
dignity of work how we honor organized
labor and all workers the waitress in
Toledo the nurse in Columbus the office
worker in Dayton the mine worker in
Coshocton it's pretty distinctive no
it's been described as gravelly raspy
and every other adjective meaning sounds
like he gargles with rocks that you can
think of but whatever word you use to
describe it Browns voice is distinctive
and authentic his voice sounds like the
guy he is a scrapper who fights like
hell every single day granted that won't
be enough to get any Kenan elected or
even get the nomination but in a field
that could be as large as 30 Oh
candidates and a campaign cycle that
does often Center on impressions and
appearances having a voice that stands
out literally is no small thing look if
you were gambling your mortgage on a
candidate yet probably go safe and pick
Joe Biden but if you're the kind of
person who's drawn to a little longer
odds and a bigger potential payoff then
I think Brown is your guy and that is
the point we make point videos twice a
week tune in every Tuesday and Thursday
for hot fresh content